ça la météo on va retrouver notre envoyé
spécial dans un instant à montpellier
dans la ville même tout s'est arrêté
pendant plusieurs heures les voitures
les bus les trains l'aéroport a
évidemment été fermé les rues désertées
amaury guibert stéphane bretenières
samuel email on devait y jouer un match
de football ce soir il est logiquement
reporté le stade de la mosson à
montpellier et noyés sous un mètre d'eau
à l'image d'une ville totalement
paralysé des pluies diluviennes depuis
ce matin et des rues presque désertes
pas de bus pas de tramway et pas de
trains le trafic a été interrompu
de nombreuses voix étant submergées été
bloqués sur la sur l'avant-bras lieu de
la voix ça l'électricité et que la pluie
qui tombait enfin c'est pourtant l'air
orages voilà
en ce qui te crois pas très loin de la
latte se vident au rythme des
évacuations
bernard cardio s'est proposé pour
faciliter les opérations et le plus dur
c'est souvent de convaincre mais pour
vous avez 3 à 3 trucs à prendre là ça
fait on n'est pas sereine et mieux mais
je vous attends je vous ai dit je vous
attends mais voyez je suis toujours là
ce couple a décidé de partir seul
bernard gardien n'attendra pas pour
vérifier les évacués sont regroupés dans
ce gymnase et beaucoup ne compte pas y
rester très longtemps là puis rentrer
chez moi et avait dormi chez moi
j'étais partir là bas une heure
ouais je vais partir je vais laisser mes
animaux là bas des militaires sont venus
prêter main forte
montpellier sa région espère en avoir
fini avec la tempête